the world is going through a financial
crisis it is challenging is difficult
there is a lot of competition for
finances and democracies where people
have to agree on a decade kind of funds
it as a challenge to be able to dedicate
money to alleviate poverty I understand
that Chinese very well I also understand
that the World Bank and other
institutions on i will have done great
work over the years with the support of
many countries making sure that we
helped before make sure that people have
access to clean water have access to
have access to nation of necessity that
we take for granted crumble and is not a
good time for us to remember those shown
up in times that there are billions of
people out there that hunger hug me now
sport we should all make sure that we
dedicate enough resources so that we
don't forget the pool we don't lose out
on an investment acquisition in the u.s.
it is very important because if all of
us turn to make sure that this message
goes out to everyone we all make sure
that whatever lifting we have to give to
to ensure people's access to what I can
lose access to in here where your people
create even you can swim around the
world the economic development is a
challenge that you've all seen party
power